Hey there, smartless fans and listeners. It's me, comedian, actor, wizard, Rory Scoville, and I'm busting into your ears right now to tell you about a new podcast that I hope you'll check out. It's called Crimeless. Every week, journalist Josh Dean and myself dive into a new story from the stupider side of the true crime world. Here is our trailer, and if it sounds like some of you'd like, just search for and follow Crimless wherever you get your podcasts. Have you ever listened to crime shows and found yourself with more questions than answers?
嘿，SmartLess的粉丝和听众们。我是喜剧演员、演员、巫师Rory Scoville，我现在闯入你们的耳朵，是为了告诉你们一个我希望你们去听的新播客。它叫《Crimeless》。每周，记者Josh Dean和我都会深入挖掘真实犯罪世界中那些更愚蠢的故事。这是我们的预告片，如果听起来是你喜欢的类型，只需在任何你收听播客的地方搜索并关注《Crimeless》即可。你有没有听过犯罪节目，结果发现自己心中的疑问比答案还多？
And what is this? How is that not a story we all know? What is this? Where is that? Why is it wet? Then boy, do we have a podcast for you. Is it a crime to cut someone's hair without their permission? And what if that person is a cat?
这是什么？为什么我们大家都不知道这个故事？这是什么？那是哪里？为什么它是湿的？那么伙计，我们有一个非常适合你的播客。未经允许剪掉别人的头发是犯罪吗？如果那个人是一只猫呢？
Is it even safe to snort human remains? What is the dumbest way to steal a quarter million dollars? Who catfish is a city? Is this even a crime? Honestly, it feels more like a high-level prank. than a crime. Introducing Crimeless,
吸食人类遗骸安全吗？偷走二十五万美元最愚蠢的方法是什么？谁会把一座城市当成网恋对象？这甚至算犯罪吗？老实说，这感觉更像是一个高级恶作剧，而不是犯罪。隆重推出《Crimeless》，
a new show from the law-abiding geniuses at smartless media, campside media, and big money players. Join me, Roy Scoble, comedian and actor,
这是一档来自SmartLess Media、Campside Media和Big Money Players守法天才们的新节目。加入我，喜剧演员兼演员Roy Scoville，
and me, Josh Dean, investigative journalist on our new weekly podcast that celebrates the amazing creativity of the world's
还有我，调查记者Josh Dean，收听我们每周更新的新播客，一起赞颂世界上
dumbest criminals. It has everything you could ever want in a show. Promiscuous primates. There are thousands of angry, horny monkeys.
最愚蠢罪犯的惊人创造力。它拥有你对节目所能期待的一切。滥交的灵长类动物。有成千上万只愤怒、发情的猴子。
Advice from the Great Beyond. I've realized you can't just out loud before the tarot card reading just go, will I ever have a threesome? We should ask a deeper questions, I think, right? Oh, I'm sorry, Josh. Am I going to have a threesome, not a deep question for you? Incredible voice acting? These guys were doing stuff that you can't even imagine with refrigerators.
来自彼岸的建议。我意识到你不能在塔罗牌占卜前大声说出“我会有三人行吗？”这种问题。我想我们应该问更深层的问题，对吧？哦，抱歉，Josh。难道“我会不会有三人行”对你来说不是个深层问题吗？令人难以置信的配音表演？这些家伙对冰箱做的事情是你无法想象的。
Well, these cats have such a different struggle. And of course, plenty of stupid crime. If you can fake your own death and still live in the same town, and all you did was change your name, you are either an incredible actor or you live in the dumbest town. I've got to assume there are some obvious textural and color differences
好吧，这些猫有着完全不同的挣扎。当然，还有大量的愚蠢犯罪。如果你能伪造自己的死亡却依然住在同一个镇上，而且你所做的仅仅是改了个名字，那你要么是一个了不起的演员，要么你住在一个最愚蠢的镇上。我不得不假设在人类骨灰和可卡因之间，
between human ashes and cocaine. I gotta say outside of the double murder, kind of a fun guy. It was an attempted double murder, to be fair. Plus game segments. I can't believe it's the hardest trivia game on the poop episode. Every week, a new crime that asks the question, wait, what?
存在一些明显的质地和颜色差异。我得说，除了那起双重谋杀案，他还是个挺有趣的人。公平地说，那是一起未遂的双重谋杀案。此外还有游戏环节。我不敢相信这是“便便”那一集中最难的冷知识游戏。每周，一个新的犯罪故事都会引出一个问题：等等，什么？
Turns on this show, folks. You cannot guess where Josh is going to take us. You don't. That's why they tune in, Rory. It's the mystery of it all. Crimeless, coming soon from smartless media, campside media, and big money players. We have great, would it, if at the end of season one,
伙计们，这节目充满了转折。你根本猜不到Josh会带我们去哪里。你猜不到的。这就是他们收听的原因，Rory。这就是它的神秘之处。《Crimeless》，即将由SmartLess Media、Campside Media和Big Money Players推出。我们有很棒的……如果第一季结束时，
you turned into like a master criminal. That's how the season should end. You and I should have to pull off a crime. Open your free Eyeheart Radio app Search Crimeless And listen now There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你变成了一个犯罪大师，那该多好。这才是这一季应该有的结局。你和我应该去实施一起犯罪。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用程序，搜索《Crimeless》并立即收听。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。